c'est un honneur
nous sommes juste amis
je commence
fait en france et j'en avais je l'engagé
tad donc sortir du labyrinthe n hésitez
pas trop pour le thème parce que pour
moi il faut vivre dans un labyrinthe et
le transformer un autre monde je vais
vous parler de mon labyrinthe et à
travers donc mon histoire vous allez
savoir la réponse donc mon plus grand
labyrinthe de neige et c'était la
chirurgie orthopédique je vais commencer
par hasard à un âge était très très
amoureux de la chirurgie générale et
avant de faire mon choix j'ai eu mon
mentor il me disait c'est la chirurgie
orthopédique typhi pour la chirurgie
orthopédie je ne savais rien
d'orthopédie pour moi étaient des gens
qui se baladait avec un marteau et de
viser un tournevis qu'est ce que
j'allais faire dans ce monde donc j'ai
choisi la chirurgie orthopédique et
j'étais perdue dans son monde donc
c'était un labyrinthe pour moi il y
avait tellement de choses à apprendre à
faire des nuits blanches des urgences au
prix ajouté jeudi l'a perdu j'en sentais
inutile
useless c'est ans d'études pour pouvoir
la vendre rien mobilisés il y avait même
des gens qui m'ont dit tu n'es pas fait
pour la chirurgie orthopédique vas-y
change de vérité vous avez qu'il ait
toujours des jugements physique ils
m'ont dit défi pour la dermato pour
totalement ce n'est pas fait pour
l'orthopédie et le comble bad et la rive
le 14 janvier j'étais jeune résidant à
l'hôpital militaire un afflux massif de
blessés et j'étais de garde
donc ma perception des choses bêtes des
tartes mélo le chercher à satisfaire ces
gens qui n'arrêtait pas de dire je n'ai
pas fait pour notre pays ensuite non
j'étais là pour sauver des gens donc
pour redonner la fonction aux gens et
tout d'un coup mon labeur entre essai
transformé en un couloir avec un but
bien précis
j'ai mobilisé toute mon énergie dans ce
couloir et jeu j'arrivais à sauver des
gens a redonné la fonction et je puise
mon énergie dans mes malades chaque
successives booster vers un autre succès
donc j'ai passé mes cinq ans sur ce
trajet là dans ce couloir
mais comme tout labyrinthe on finit par
se perdre
j'ai passé mon concours d'assistanat je
suis devenu donc assistons universitaire
et monibou a pris le dessus
malheureusement je me voyais comme un
super chirurgien et je cherchais plus
tous les exploits a épaté mes étudiants
sont pensés vraiment ami malade je me
suis égaré de mon chemin et j'ai perdu
entre-temps khalil humble pour devenir
quelqu'un d'autre malheureusement mais
kiev de lui l'icône du rock bixente
recourir à z donc il ya eu un incident
où je me suis donc ré hospitalisé en
réanimation on m'a enlevé un partie du
poumon et je suis sorti après à moi avec
un membre gauche supérieur qui n'était
non fonctionnels et une fonte musculaire
et nord je ne pouvais même pas me tenir
debout donc
là sert à lire le boxeur qui a pris la
relève je pouvais pas déclaré forfait
dans j'ai bataillé et je suis revenu sur
scène mais cette fois avec un mental est
encore quitté brisé mais guéri du coup
il était devenu plus fort
et lorsque je rentrais au bloc cette
fois ci je me sentais invincible
parce que je suis passé de l'autre côté
je savais ce que mes malades santé et
geste est là pour une cause noble un
encadré les jeunes qui étaient autour de
moi donc c'était déjà le hockey quescan
est tout juste que je faisais qui
répétait à l'âme au café thé mot par mot
ce que je disais je n'avais pas le droit
de ne pas être parfait elle est reçue
pour passer des fourmis sage
donc je me sentais invincible d'ailleurs
le calot que je porte porte le dessin
animé dont qui s'appelle berserk je
savais je ne savais pas si vous le
connaissez donc il ya sûrement des gens
qui le connaissent donc d'art certes ça
veut dire la traduction c'est le gris
lorsqu'ils se sont invincibles dans un
champ de bataille et qui se sont
capables de choses surnaturelles et moi
entonnant le bus tuerie je me sentais
comme ça parce que la cause était plus
grande que mes succès était plus grande
que
faire le fanfaron devant les élèves mais
plutôt c'était de redonner la fonction à
mes élèves de par mes patients de passer
de grand message à mes élèves et jean
donné cinq jours avant et c'est ce qui
m'a donné l'opportunité d'ouvrir mon
esprit après tout je me disais est ce
que c'est suffisant pour madame est-ce
que je dois me limiter aux techniques
qui sont disponibles uniquement en
tunisie je devais chercher d'autres
solutions out of the box qui manque aux
roues et là j'ai eu recours à une équipe
d'ingénieurs et si présentes qui sont
magnifiques les gens porter le dossier
au staff médical pour les discuter et
moi je portais le dossier au staff des
ingénieurs
trouvez moi la solution je me disais si
ça qui m'a permis de faire non des
exploits chirurgicale moi je voyais
plutôt que c'était un moyen pour
accomplir ce que je voulais vraiment je
me voyais comme un instrument du dieu ce
dernier vit donc je pouvait redonner la
fonction je prenais pouvait redonner la
vie j'étais en train de former des gens
exceptionnels qui m'ont poussé à
m'améliorer et que m'ont poussé à
devenir un homme meilleur avant d'autres
insurgés un meilleur donc j'ai trouvé
des solutions ailleurs parce que mon
esprit pour une fois était ouvert je
n'ai pas limitée dans le couloir de
faire un succès sur j call ou duke
tremblay a fait sera fait à fait ceux ci
après tout une prothèse qui contrôle 30
mille dinars n'importe où n'importe
quelle main n'importe quel imbécile peut
la mettre mais le vrai et le vrai succès
c'était de pouvoir sauver les gens
c'était le moyen que j'ai utilisées et
malheureusement des fois on applaudit le
moyen et non pas de but on applaudit le
fait qu'on a mis une prothèse à 3000
dinars mais non le but le vrai exploit
on est arrivé à sauver quelqu'un on est
arrivé à sauver son membre non qu'on a
mis une prothèse à 38,10 marque désolé
mais m quant à elle bloquée mort est
faite à la protesta 30 à sais pas c'est
pas un exploit alors le planning ouvrir
son esprit est toujours se dit se dire
pourquoi on est là lorsqu on s'égare
dans le labyrinthe on doit toujours
toujours se souvenir pourquoi on est là
et du coup je me suis dit ce n'est pas
l'habit rentes ces moments après tout
j'étais en train de m'exploser moi même
j'étais en train de tester mes limites
je suis en train de découvrir des
capacités que je savais pas j'étais doué
dans la modélisation par exemple dans le
dessin des anciens je ne savais pas que
j'avais soudan là et parce que j'étais
passé de limites de penser dans un
couloir restreint et je n'avais pas peur
d'explorer mon labyrinthe il était là
pour que j'explore moi même je voulais
explorer demi limites et je voulais
guidé mes étudiants à travers donc ses
labyrinthes et du coup il est devenu mon
monde c'est quoi la vie son challenge si
on sort du labyrinthe et après le défi
c'est fini pourquoi on ignore donc si on
se focalise à sortir du labyrinthe et on
voit juste la sortie on va zapper tout
le voyage à travers donc c'est un voyage
dans lequel on explore mme nous mêmes on
explore nous limite il ya une citation
que j'aime très bien qui a été dit dans
le film gladiator en fait je vais citer
l'art
qui est la source de toute inspiration
ce que l'on fait dans sa vie résonne
dans l'éternité très accessible
radiateur ce que l'on fait dans sa vie
résonnent dans l'éternité donc en
résonnent dans l'éternité à travers nos
accomplissements
à travers ce qu'on fait on choisit
d'être le sujet lamda
personnes souvient de nous ont choisi
d'être c'est lui qui va résonner dans
l'éternité il faut ouvrir l'esprit il
faut se dire non c'est pas mes limites
je dois pousser mes limites encore plus
je dois ouvrir cette porte là dans ce
labyrinthe qui n'est d'autre qu'un
voyage
en entrant labyrinthe on en sort si on
veut sortir un mois je veux pas sortir
de mon avis rentes parce que chaque jour
aussi un chirurgien meilleur je suis un
homme heures pourquoi sortir du
labyrinthe si c'est la fin des défis ça
sert à rien de continuer à vivre marche
si vous êtes d'accord mais une vie sont
divines où vous pas d'être vécue l'art
est donc ce que je vous dis c'est
raisonner dans l'éternité par vos
accomplissements nous dit ne vous dit
pas après toutes ces années d'études
qu'est ce que je vais en faire après tôt
ou même après tout donc si mon élevage
donc après tout à quoi servent toutes
ces années d'études vous allez vous dire
ça et vous allez vous perdre ne vous
inquiétez pas mais vous allez vous
retrouver en une version meilleur de
vous vous allez être plus fort donc
n'ayez pas peur d'explorer le labyrinthe
niveau perdre c'est l'essence même du
voyage des voyages c'est un voyage dans
lequel on explore les limites donc
résonné dans l'éternité et lorsque vous
allez vous perdre dans le labyrinthe
juste souvenez vous pourquoi vous le
faites pour épater quelqu'un pour
acquérir une voiture
et acquérir une maison ou bien surtout
satisfaire qui l'ultime l'ultime
satisfaction qu'on n'est jamais
satisfait de ce qu'on fait mais
lorsqu'on se rappelle pourquoi honda on
veut le labyrinthe
redevient un couloir avec un but lorsque
six sorties de la réanimation j'étais
dans un puits
je ne voyais pas l'enfant ma vie était
finie mais je me suis rappelé pourquoi
j'étais là pour quoi j'avais ce don va
je devais devenir ce que j'étais en une
version meilleur donc je vous dis
perdez-vous
découvrait découvrez vos limites et
surtout surtout résonné dans l'éternité
et merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]